comment ça se fait qu'il y a tellement
peu de filles ici il y a pas de filles
parce que ils ont peur de descendre et
pourquoi ils ont mauvaise réputation les
gars avant ils avaient mauvaise
réputation dans la cité mais maintenant
non parce qu'on vient tous dans la
salle nous sommes à aubervillier commune
de la région
parisienne au milieu de ces immeubles
sans histo
nous avons posé une
caméra c'est que nous avions entendu
parler d'une bande de jeunes qui se
réunissaient dans le
quartier une bande qu'est-ce que c'est
le mot lui-même n'est pas très
sympathique il n'inspire pas
confiance
[Musique]
pour en savoir plus nous avons pris
contact avec certains d'entre
eux nous avons réussi à nous faire
inviter dans cette cave nous et nos
caméras pour la circonstance les filles
et les garçons ont décidé de décorer un
peu
mais ça n'est pas le cadre lui-même qui
nous intéressait
plutôt eux avec qui nous avions envie de
parler pour comprendre ce qui les avait
amené à se regrouper
là vous occupez vous avez combien de
jeunes dont vous occupez à l'OM
d'adhérent enfin d'adhérent à l'omme je
on on a pas loin de
270 ouais et en tout le nombre de jeunes
qu'on s'occupe dans
l'année ça varie entre je me rappelle
pas c'est pour ça que je voulais VO CHM
ça doit varier
entre 1000 ou 2000 dis-moi André cette
cette cave là cette salle dans laquelle
vous vous réunissez ça fait combien de
temps que vous l'avez environ le 15
septembre enfin juste après le mois
d'août enfin disons 12 septembre on a
commencé mais ça vous ça vous est venu
comment l'idée de d'avir C on était on
était sur ici là dans le parc d'enfants
là on jouait enfin on s'amusait comme on
pouvait parce que pour aller au café ça
n intéressait pas toujours alors un jour
on a eu l'idée on a entendu parler qu'il
y avait la salle de livre salle de jeune
de livre on a éit demandé au gardien il
nous a donné les clés c'est quoi la
salle de jeûe c'est cette cave là enfin
c'était une salle où il y avait des
jeunes au commencement qui avaient fait
quelque chose essayé de faire une salle
de jeune mais ça n'avait pas marché
c'est ça et un jour vous avez appris de
nouveau que cette salle était libre on a
demandé au gardien il nous a donné les
clés on a commencé à à venir ici pour
s'amuser enfin et il y a un petit peu
tous les jeunes du quartier qui viennent
ah non non au commencement non c'était
un petit groupe seulement ça se passait
plutôt bien ou plutôt mal
ah il y avait des désaccords des foisis
dans la cité qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
des désaccords il y avait des bandes
rivales il y avvec qui bah de petites
bandes enfin de clans il y avait dire
deux clans et les deux clans enfin non
quand même pas on allait on en venait
pas au main vous étiez pas ensemble
avant qument ça se passait non on était
pas ensemble et qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
avant alors c'est comm dit c'était le
groupe qui allait à l'école et le groupe
qui travaillait puis nous on les on les
fréquentait pas quand on les voyait et
pourquoi toi tu étais du groupe qui
travaillait ouais et alors qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire on les fréquentait pas bah
non on les aimait pas quoi mais alors ça
donnait des des petites bagares entre
vous des trucs dans bah ouais le soir on
descendait là et puis on on CIT quelque
chose on Remon après et comment ça s'est
arrangé bah après on s'est rendu compte
que
ça c'était mieux de venir ici quoi que
de rester au café parce qu'on était tout
le temps au café nous et vous avez
décidé de faire l'unité entre les deux
clans quoi ouais voilà on dépensait tout
notre argent Lab tufé et tout alors on a
préféré venir ici quoi mais alors
comment ça s'est passé quand vous êtes
venu ici vous êtes venu vous leur avez
dit les gars fini la BAGAR non enfin on
n pas dit ça comme ça on est venu on
regardait on faisait rien quoi après ils
ont compris que on voulait plus vous
aviez des
intentions de travailler puis ils sont
descendus un jour comme ça nous ont
regardé quelquesuns nous ont aidé on
avait pas confiance en eux au
commencement vraiment on disait ceci
viennent là ils vont tout CER et
après après ils sont commencé à venir on
a pris confiance on a dit bon ben on va
se mettre avec eux onire confiance c'est
pas la peine de les laisser comme ça
puis on a pas le droit de les laisser
dehors la sal est pour tout le monde on
a commencer à monter les activités enfin
on commence à à danser à tout ils sont
venus ils ont commencé à prendre des
Paes dans les activités on les a laissé
ça commence à tourner tu dis ils ont
commencé à prendre des postes dans les
activités par on aura donné confiance et
ça veut dire quoi que vous avez organisé
les activités bah oui enfin on a essayé
de un G pour le bar pour les disques
pour les boissons si enfin un peu pour
tout pour les sorties aussi et ça s'est
bien passé ça ça s'est bien passé ça oui
quelquefois enfin les les les
responsables ne sont pas restés
longtemps pourquoi oh parce qu'on leur
faisait des
reproches on leur disait il manque 200
francs dans la caisse et puis on prenait
ça à mal il disait ça y est on prend
pour un voleur alors il s'en allait
c'était fini il personne voulait prendre
de responsabilité il n reste quelquesuns
seulement il reste de ou TR je crois
c'est ça le
problème Jean-Pierre tu es le
responsable du bar toici depuis combien
de mois depuis 2 mois ça se passe bien
non pas tout à fait
c'estàdire il pi des bouteilles tu vois
et puis trend pas les bouteilles vid tu
vois les bouill tu vois tout ça c'est
difficile à organiser quoi voilà tu es
en déficite ou quoi voilà je dois
dessouer la caisse je dois dessouer un
potei j'y arrive pas puis je travaille
pour et on t'engueule voilà tous les
côtés et dis-moi Claude tu as aussi une
responsabilité ouais je tenais la caisse
moi tu tenais la caisse et tu la tiens
plus non je la tiens plus parce que il y
en a qui se sont permis de dire
que que j'emprentais de l'argent dans la
caisse puis comme c'est pas vrai ça m'a
pas plusu j'ai largué tout je sur
l'allée je me suis de tu plus de rien
mes copains il s pas permis de me dire
ça parces savent que c'est pas c'est pas
mes copains c'est des gars que j'ai
connu comme ça quand les deux groupes il
se sont formés c'est un des GS de
l'autre groupe qui s'est permis de me
dire ça et ça ça t'a touché alors ouais
ça m'a touché parce que avant j'étais
assez voleur d'accord je le
reconnaisentre copain non je l'aurais
pas fait je pense pas que je l'aurais
fait comme je suis sûr que je l'ai pas
fait ça ser à rien tu dis j'éta Bur ça
veut dire quoi tu étais délinquant un
peu ou quoi ouais j'étais délinquant je
pens au P du je pens à peu près partout
puis après je sais pas en se groupant on
a commencé à comprendre que ça valait
pas la peine de faire des conneries ça
nous rapportait surtout rien du tout ça
n ça nous rapportait que des
emmerdements à la fin on s'est groupé pu
on a eu sal là qui nous a apporté
beaucoup qui nous a fait beaucoup de
choses nousmême grâce à la salle tu as
pu oui grâce à la salle j'ai pu quand
même commencer à comprendre que c'était
vraiment se dépenser s'amuser sans faire
de conneries j'ai vu que c'était ça j'ai
commencé je continue ça veut dire
quoiune fois que vous aviez trouvé la
salle une fois que tu étais avec les
copains là tu étais moins seul peut-être
ou j'étais moins seul parce que j'étais
plus enviré je me sentais pas seul comme
avant bon j'avais rien à faire je
rencontre un mec dans la rue bon je on
discut puis on en à faire une connerie
puis ça partait sur la connerie puis on
faisit pu cétait terminé mais là j'ai
retrouvé vraiment des copains ça va
mieux je me sens mieux je me sens plus
seulant dis-moi Françoise a une question
que je me pose en regardant comme ça
comment ça qu'il y a tellement peu de
filles ici il y a pas de filles parce
que ils ont peur de descendre ils ont
peur de descendre pourquoi parce que
c'est à cause des gars qu'on les connaît
pas tout ça ouais et puis les parents
veulent pas aussi mais pourquoi ils ont
mauvaise réputation les gars avant ils
avaient mauvaise réputation dans la cité
mais maintenant non parce qu'on vient
tous dans la salle ils avaient mauvaise
réputation quand il y avait les deux
bandes dehors et que oui parce qu'avant
c'est vrai c tout dans les escaliers
tout ça alors c'était mal vu ouais
maintenant bah comme on vient tous ici
on fait fait toutes conneries dans les
dans les bâtiments alors maintenant les
filles commencent à descendre oui
commencent à descendre tes copines
arrivent un peu oui ils arrivent puis
même on est descendu à peu près tous
ensemble et comment ils réagissent les
voisins maintenant est-ce qu'ils se sont
habitués ou est-ce que ils regardent
encore ça d'un mauvais œil ils sont pas
tellement contents hein les voisins dans
l'ensemble ils sont pas contents l'autre
fois on a eu une réunion là sur la salle
ouais il y a deux trois voisins qui sont
t descendu ils avaient une pétition dans
la main pourquoi bah ils disent qu'il y
a trop de bruit il y a trop d'aller venu
enfin il y qu' a des Correau qui sont
cinés à la porte de la cave il y a plus
de poigné et dis-moi ils ont raison ou
ils ont pas raison pour la poignée le
cor ils ont raison mais quand ils
raconte qu'on est à 100 dans la salle
c'est pas vrai ça et tu crois toi qu'il
y a trop de bruit ou il y en a pas assez
quand les portes sont fermé quand les
portes sont fermées il y a juste dans le
couloir si on entend un peu mais quand
ils sont chez eux en PU tu bien quand
par exemple à la salle bah moi je
travaille enfin j'arrive à 5h je rentre
temp chez moi je viens directement ici
avant de rentrer chez toi tu passes ici
déjà ouais je reste jusqu'à 7h30 ouais
après je monte manger je redescends là
jusqu'à 10h des fois minuit tous les
jours tous les jours disant les parents
ou mon père à chaque fois il me dit avec
ta salle tu rentres plus hein parce que
avant je sortais pas tellement je
rentrais le bonheur quoi mais depis qu'
à la salle je rentre tard le soir et
pourquoi tu viens dans cette salle tu es
pas bien chez toi si je suis bien mais
là il y a tous les copains c'est plus
libre enfin on peut parler quoi est-ce
que vous êtes nombreux chez toi non les
six six enfants oui et chez toi si
enfants six enfants chez toi aussi ça
fait peut-être un peu petit aussi non
non bah c'est assez grand vous avez
quand même plus de place pour vivre ici
ah oui quand même et alors qu'est-ce que
vous faites le soir comme ça quand vous
êtes ensemble B on regarde la télé où on
écoute des disques quo des fois j mais
regardez la télé ou écoutez du dis que
vous pouvez le faire chez vous aussi non
oui mais on est mieux là on est en TR
Copin on peut s'amuser quoi en regardant
la télé on peut parler tout parler de
quoi de l'émission ouais
voilà
Jeanjean je voudrais te poser la
question suivante quand tu étais un peu
le responsable ici au départ oui au
départ m maintenant actuellement encore
mais vu qu'on a cette nouvelle s qu'on
va approprier qui va nous être accordé
ben on essayie Momi moi c'est assez
difficile d'avoir des responsabilités
énormes vis-à-vis de la salle d'être si
tu veux le permanent au sein de cette
salle-ci enfin mais autrement j'arrive à
palier puis à m'occuper un peu de la
salle mais seulement voilà la première
fois qu'on est venu ici il semblait que
tous les copains dans la salle
t'accepaient tous comme chef comme
responsable la deuxème fois qu'on est
venu c'était un mois après tu t'étais
marié
entretemps il semblait qu'il t'acceptait
quand même beaucoup moins bien il n
disait Jeanjean depuis qu'il est marié
il sup plus de nous il a trop d'autorité
comment tu peux expliquer ça moi
j'explique il s'est passé d'autres
choses mon mariage n'a rien à voir
dedans je crois pas du moins un sens
mais je vois que mariaashi il a quelque
chose à voir c'est que je peux le temps
que je leur accordais avant euh
c'està-dire la plus grande partie du
temps que je leur accordais avant je
suis obligé de la couper pour pour faire
pour ma vie familiale pour ma femme quoi
alors mais dans l' dans le reste du
temps j'essaie de quand même de
d'intercaler mes mes activités ici de
m'occuper des jeunes qui sont ici dans
la salle oui mais ils disent ils disent
surtout jeanan que tu as pris trop
d'autorité depuis que tu es marié on est
obligé de prendre de l'autorité parce
que ici cette salle-ci ça va fini on va
avoir une neuve Onir une nouvelle salle
là et de cette nouvelle salle il
faudrait quand même que les gars
comprennent qu'il faut qu'il s'en occupe
alors ici on leur a laissé un peu les
mains libres faire ce que bon on leur
donner des responsabilités au gars au
départ ça allait bien il s'en occupai
mais petit à petit c'est comme tout ça
va en dégradant alors s'il y a pas po un
peu des fois on est obligé de serrer la
vis c'estàd de le de les R à l'ordre et
puis leur dire bon ça c'est pas bon à
faire il faut vous occuper ici c'est
d'accord mais de côté on fera pas mais
est-ce que tu ne crois pas que c'est
peut-être pas exactement la bonne
méthode pour apprendre à des gens à
avoir des responsabilités de serrer la
vis comme tu dis NON je suis d'accord
avec toi de par exemple de de bloquer
des gars c'est pas normal il faut leur
laisser une liberté c'est des gars qui
sont ici ils viennent ici bienvellement
ils rent comme ils veulent mais si ça
leur plaît pas ils s'on he c'està dire
quand les gars ils viennent ici bon ma
qui jusqu'à 10h 11h du soir et tu
rentres quand je reviens du travail à
11h 11h30 l'lectrophone il marche encore
bon B je je suis plus tout à fait
d'accord avec eux à cause des voisins en
fait et ca justement il faut bon ben ici
il faut comprendre que c'est une salle
auudessus il y a le locataire le
locatair bon ben ils sont assez mais il
faut les comprendre aussi ces locataires
là le soir à 11h si ça commence
éctrophone il cri comm 31 il faut
comprendre que il va être chez eux aussi
hein mais je crois que maintenant vu
qu'on va voir la salle il faut leur
donner responsabilité faut leur faire
comprendre que cette sallel elle est à
eux hein que ce qu'ils font ici sera pas
d'accord de l'ARE côté parce qu'il faut
qu'il respecte la salle alors qu'ici ne
commence pas à la respect
bon ben c'est comme tout une salle ici
bon il y a toujours quelqu'un qui va
détériorer une petite partie et ça va
continuer de l'autre côté il faut le
faire comprendre que cetteette petite
parti là il faud jamais la détériorer ce
que tu veux me dire au fond c'est que
ici il faut qu'ils apprennent à vivre
ensemble c'est ça c'est ça c'est qu'
apprendre déjà ici à vivre ensemble pour
vivre pour arriver dans l'autre salle
tout prêt tout dispo puis occuper c'est
dire faire les activités plus facilement
qu'on a moins d'embêtement dans l'autre
salle mais alors là il a un problème qui
se pose toujours la première fois où on
est venu ils étaient tous gonflés à bloc
ils avaient la salle depuis un mois ou
de disait tu vas voir c'est formidable
on va faire du karting on va faire des
tas de trucs puis on est revenu un mois
après au bout d'un mois après c'était la
débandade générale ils étaient tous
désespérés en disant il y a pas un gars
qui garde des responsabilités il y a
rien à faire ici c'est fini mais non
c'est pas fini la vie la voit pas de la
même façon peut-être que moi je la vois
parce que je sais pas moi je vois la vie
bon ben qu'il faut se battre dans eux
bon ben si si on leur apporte du tout
fait du tout cuit je sont d'accord mais
à partir du moment qu'il faut le
construire au DESP ils seront tout
contents ilsessont d'y arriver mais à
partir d'un moment ben ça bloquera et
est-ce que tu crois que quand même ce
qui s'est passé ici jusqu'à maintenant
la manière dont ils ont eu cette salle
dont ils auront la salle est-ce que
c'est quand même positif est-ce que cet
apprentissage il commence quand même à
le faire oui il font oui il fut parce
que comme je t'avais dit au départ quand
tu es arrivé ici la première fois on
avait discuté et puis je t'avais dit
qu'il y avait de deux deux bandes de
jeunes quoi ce du fond puis ce d'ici
quoi al les jeunes les jeunes ils sont
ils se sont groupés ensemble pour faire
cette salle là déjà moi ça m'a fait un
énorme mal ça m'a remonté un peu le Mor
et puis c'est énormément bien parce que
bon ben les jeunes qu's ont construit
cette salle là ensemble c'està dire
qu'ils ont appris à vivre en communauté
ensemble c'estàd quand ils iront dans
l'autre salle déjà là il a il y aura un
problème en moins c'estàd c'é un gros
problème pour nous on avait essayé avant
c'était difficile il y a des jeunes qui
arrivent bon ben il y en a qui peuvent
plus ou moins se voir c'est comme tout
et enfin là ça s'est bien arrangé c'est
bien ils sont bien regroupés ils ont
construit cette salle là impeccablement
et maintenant bah ils vont repartir
j'espère quand il vont arriver dans
l'autre ça va être bien
et on envisage justement de fabriquer
nous-même cette maison de jeun
c'est-à-dire ça sera porortter ce sera
des parois préfabriqué il y aura que la
monture métallique à installer
simplement et nous envisageons aussi le
problème
de de la montée d'étudier le plan que ça
soit 5 ou six jeunes qu'envisage
justement cette construction c'està que
la maison de jeûe c'est vous qui la
fabriquerez on vous donnera les éléments
et vous la montrz c'est-à-dire au départ
c'était nous qui devions la fabriquer
mais ça pose un problème élémentaire
c'estàdire que chaque vice chaque boulon
doit être placé à l'endroit don il doit
être mis et en plus ça demande un
travail assez sérieux dis vous
participerez à la mais voilà il y aura
une
participation des qui sont ici
c'està-dire penser un élément ainsi de
suite quoi participer à cette
construction sans faire le montage
comend moment qu'ilur quand Mme peu faê
responsable voilà c'est à partir c'est
ça c'est normal quand on fait quelque
chose et qu'on le fait avec vous et donc
on sera responsable par la suite il
faut prendre soin de qu'est-ce qu'on
aura parce que c'est important et
dis-moi CGE est-ce qu'elle sera cette
maisenteur alors elle sera située entre
des bâtiments qui se
trouvent une très grande espanade et
elle sera située anciennement dans un
jeu où il y avait du S juste à côté
d'ici juste à côté voilà c'est vrai REM
ça va drôement changer le paysage quand
ça va drôlement changer quand il AAS la
maison
làbas ça
va
bon puisquon est puisquon est par là et
que la maison de des jeunes sera par là
plus tard on pourrait essayer de de
rêver un peu quoi qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait y faire dans cette maison des
jeunes quand elle sera là
onensé et toi c'est to 'en occuper de ça
oui avec un autre copain alors comment
vous les feriez ces cararting bah
c'estàdire comment tu t'occupes de
mécanique toi ou oui enfin je fais la
mécanique et vous en fabriqueriez
combien oh ben c'est quand même assez
difficile à dire parce que c'est dur à
faire ouais deux tris ah oui quand même
de TR ouais mettrait quand même à peu
près 6 mois et après vous iriez les
essayer ah oui on IR les essayer bien
sûr tout le monde en ferait bah oui
pourquoi pas tour alors et qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire encore hein B on
pourrait faire un labo photo c'est toi
qui t'en écuper pr ouais pourquoi tu es
spécialiste ouais j'i déjà fait en
colonie quand j'avais 10 ans voilà et tu
crois que ça intéresse les autres ouais
ça les intéresse tous parler ça plaisir
il voudrait tous faire de la photo ouais
ouais tous mais quoi de la photo de
famille de je sais pas moi prendre les
paysages des copains c'est ça la photo
d'art quoi ouais hein on va faire un
journal aussi pour développer nos
activités extérieures intérieures maison
de jeun tout ça quel titre il aura le
journal c'est pas encore on va lu donner
un titre vous avez pensé non pas encore
on en a parlé mais on n pas d'accord sur
le titre quel titre vous avez pensé
il y en a qui disent la voix des jeune
l'ch des jeunes il en a qui dit
l'espérance en fait tout ça ça reste à
voir ouis et qu'est-ce qu'on dit fa
encore il ait un coin destente qui
consisterait en mibiiathèque qui serait
fourni en policier et autres et en
particulier des livres pour
s'instruire puis des livres qu'on
pourrait mettre aussi en vitrine c'est
dire qu' sera en exposition
permanente aussi des jeux de société
pour que les gars puissent jouer
s'ennuyer et des cartes aussi pour les
concours de décheets enfin de dame c'est
toi Tito qui sera un peu le responsable
des activités dites culturelles en
quelque S mais pourquoi bah parce que je
me suis je suis intéressé par le théâtre
surtout puis ça m'a poussé aussi vers
les livres en du théâtre oui j'en ai
fait pendant 3 ans tout ça au groupe
firmagi à auberviller en patronage avec
le théâtre tu voudrais essayer d'en
faire un peu là oui je vraisessay en
faire les intéressés surtout et comment
ça se passera une fois que vous aurez la
maison de jeune il y aura un responsable
oui il y aura un responsable pour
superviser les activités c'est-à-dire un
animateur un animateur oui tu les jeunes
se regroupent enfin il et j'ai déjà vu
une de ces maisons de jeunes on a
l'impression de vivre de vouloir se
reposer et puis on donnera différentes
activités pour qu'il puisse justement ne
pas s'ennuyer et qui ça sera le
responsable ben on en a discuté enfin
j'ai été désigné comme responsable pour
cette maison et alors qu'est-ce qui va
se passer avec la cave elle va
disparaître ah non la cave ne
disparaîtra pas au contraire on va
essayer de pouvoir la garder pour faire
une activité dans cette cave mais
simplement une activité simplement ENIT
ce qui sera bien avec la maison de jeune
si un jour elle est vraiment là et si
elle marche c'est qu'en fait c'est tous
les jeunes de la cité vous pourrez avoir
ah oui oui au contraire ben c'est que
justement c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut que
tous les jeunes puissent se réunir avoir
des contacts entre eux et s'amuser enfin
à différentes activités ouaisêtre se non
voilà si tu me montrais un peu Serge où
est-ce qu'elle sera cette m comm ça
fais-moi le plan un peu
ouis on Esser
ça je sais pas
d'ici d'ici environ d'ici jusqu'à la
bordure du du trottoir la bordure des
pouses
[Musique]
ouais
bag
[Musique]